digamos que tú eres el dueño del único
hotel que está en una ciudad y por una
amplia variedad de razones tal vez todos
los miembros del ayuntamiento de la
ciudad son tus amigos o por lo que sea
nadie más puede construir un hotel en
esa ciudad es decir hay barreras
insuperables para entrar en ese mercado
en esta situación tienes un monopolio
eres el único jugador del mercado y
existen barreras muy muy muy exigentes
para entrar al mercado ahora esta es la
típica estructura de costos y la curva
de demanda de un monopolio ya hemos
hablado del costo marginal el cual al
principio desciende ligeramente para
después ascender y podemos debatir si
esto es cierto para un hotel o no pero
este es el típico modelo que se estudia
y luego mientras tu costo marginal esté
por debajo de tu costo total promedio el
costo total promedio tiende hacia abajo
después llega a un punto mínimo donde se
intersectan y después tiende hacia
arriba ya que el costo marginal aumenta
el costo promedio y la curva de demanda
para un monopolio nos recuerda a una
curva de demanda de mercado cuando los
precios son altos es decir cuando los
precios la habitación del hotel por
noche son altos entonces pocas personas
los demandan y si los precios son bajos
entonces muchos los demandarán ahora
algo que ya hemos hablado con muchos
detalles en otros vídeos es que la curva
de ingreso marginal es diferente a la
curva de la demanda de un monopolio esto
se debe a que si fueras a cobrar una
tarifa de 500 pesos por noche
podrías ser capaz de dar una habitación
por noche pero no las demás y si quieres
que se alquilen dos habitaciones bueno
tendrás que cobrar un poco menos
tal vez 400 pesos no sólo por esa
habitación así que estaríamos un poco
más abajo de esta curva de demanda
cuando cobras 400 pesos por la segunda
habitación es porque alguien no está
dispuesto a pagar 500 pesos entonces
tendrás que bajar también el precio de
la primera habitación así que en las
empresas monopólicas la tarifa que
cobras a uno de los consumidores será la
tarifa que se cubre a todos los
consumidores ahora ya sé qué es lo que
estás pensando algunos de ustedes dirán
oye eso no es siempre lo que pasa en un
hotel y es justo por esto que elegí este
ejemplo porque primero podemos ver la
situación donde se cobra a todos lo
mismo y después podemos ver la situación
que se conoce como discriminación de
precios en donde no tienes que cobrar a
todos por igual
pero vamos primero al modelo donde le
cobramos a todos lo mismo cuando pasamos
de una habitación con el precio de 500
pesos a dos habitaciones con el precio
de 400 pesos tu ingreso marginal no
tiene un incremento de 400 porque esta
habitación que antes costaba 500 ahora
cuesta 400 pesos también entonces vas de
500 a 800 tu ingreso marginal incrementa
en 300 vas de un total de 500 a un total
de 400 más 400 y 800 en total es por
esto y vamos a dar detalles importantes
en otros vídeos lo haremos con tablas y
números y te encargo que los veas es por
esto que la curva de ingreso marginal
para el monopolio tiene el doble de la
pendiente negativa que tu curva de la
demanda por lo tanto así se verá su
curva de ingreso marginal ya hemos
hablado en varios vídeos que para
cualquier empresa es racional producir
la cantidad del punto donde se
intersectan el costo marginal
ingreso marginal por lo que este
monopolio producirá esta cantidad y el
precio que se obtendrá al observar la
curva de la demanda es este precio que
tenemos aquí ok y podemos pensar en cuál
será su ganancia económica para cada
habitación que cobres a ese precio si su
costo total promedio es esta curva de
verde entonces la diferencia será la
ganancia económica que obtengas por
habitación y después al multiplicarlo
por el número total de habitaciones nos
da esta área que es la ganancia
económica de la empresa
ahora aún existe un excedente del
consumidor aquí es decir es una ganancia
que los consumidores obtienen mucho más
allá de lo que están pagando ya que el
excedente del consumidor en este caso es
todo esto
entonces la primera persona que tal vez
estaba dispuesta a pagar 500 pesos por
habitación ahora es capaz de obtener el
precio de mercado que todos son capaces
de conseguir que es tal vez 300 pesos
por habitación ahora esta ganancia por
unidad es para el consumidor también
hemos visto que hay una pérdida de
eficiencia aquí tienes una asignación
eficiente cuando el costo marginal es
igual a la curva de la demanda y como ya
hemos estudiado en otros vídeos esta
área es nuestra pérdida de eficiencia
bueno es momento de imaginar otro
escenario digamos que somos un hotel
donde intentamos captar la mayor
cantidad de personas que estén
dispuestas a pagar como sea posible y te
daré un escenario idealista esto no
existe realmente en el mundo real pero
nos servirá para pensar un caso extremo
digamos que tú eres capaz de adquirir
una computadora que puede leer la mente
de las personas
y que cada vez que alguien llame para
cotizar una habitación pueda saber con
exactitud cuánto está dispuesto a pagar
por lo tanto si llamo la computadora
dirá sal está en disposición de pagar
por esta habitación 375 pesos entonces
me das una cotización por 375 pesos por
lo que yo diré perfecto al kilo entonces
cuando la primera persona que tiene una
disposición de pagar un precio elevado
ya me lo que haremos es darle una
cotización de 500 pesos y alquilar a la
habitación en esta situación cada
habitación adicional no cambia el precio
de las otras que era lo que causaba que
el ingreso marginal tuviera esta rápida
pendiente descendiente
en cambio por cada habitación adicional
obtienes estos precios en esta situación
tu curva de la demanda va a ser igual a
tu curva del ingreso marginal déjame
ponerlo eres capaz de discriminar los
precios discriminación de precios es el
término general para cobrar diferentes
precios a diferentes clientes a
diferentes consumidores con base en la
idea de su disposición a pagar y tal vez
suene mal en la vida real no queremos
discriminar a las personas pero la
discriminación de precios es una cosa
muy legítima y de hecho puedes ver qué
pasa como no se en la industria de los
hoteles en donde intentarán comprar
distintos precios a distintas personas
según lo que puedan pagar esencialmente
bueno por la misma habitación si vas a
un hotel es común que un huésped de una
habitación aledaña la tuya pague un
precio distinto al tuyo
y otro ejemplo son las aerolíneas que
también hacen lo mismo ahora ellas no
son capaces de hacerlo de manera
perfecta como lo acabamos de describir
con esta computadora mágica pero lo
hacen dependiendo del lugar en el avión
o te puedes cambiar tu boleto o no o
cancelar tu reservación todo esto te va
a dar un precio distinto además que el
precio cambia a lo largo del tiempo
entonces lo que intentan es capturar
tanto como sea posible la disposición a
pagar de los consumidores pero si
hablamos de esta situación extrema donde
podemos cobrar a cada uno lo que puede
pagar entonces cuál será la cantidad
racional que debe producir el monopolio
para maximizar sus ganancias bueno una
vez más
buscaremos donde center seca el costo
marginal con el ingreso marginal pero
esta vez la curva del ingreso marginal
es la curva de la demanda
por lo tanto la cantidad producida será
esta de aquí esta es la cantidad que el
monopolio debe producir y cuál es el
precio que obtiene es bueno pausa el
vídeo y piénsalo
tal vez sientas la tentación de solo ir
de manera horizontal por aquí decir que
este es el precio que obtenemos como lo
hicimos aquí pero recuerda ahora eres
capaz de obtener un precio distinto para
cada consumidor ya que no tenemos un
único precio para todos como en este
primer ejemplo podemos fijarnos en la
cantidad que producimos y podemos ver el
costo total promedio en esta cantidad
producida aunque recuerda la ganancia
por habitación va a depender de la
disposición a pagar del consumidor si la
primera persona paga mucho por la
habitación entonces no tendríamos ningún
excedente del consumidor como en el
primer ejemplo ya que todo esto será lo
que acumulará la empresa y ese será el
caso para todos estos consumidores
en este escenario extremo
ahora tenemos una situación increíble
piensa que cuando esta empresa
monopólica es capaz de discriminar los
precios su ganancia económica es mayor
mientras que el excedente del consumidor
se redujo al discriminar los precios y
en este ejemplo extremo observa
desapareció pero también puedes ver que
este caso es una asignación eficiente
donde producimos la cantidad en donde el
costo marginal es igual al ingreso
marginal